el ataque aéreo que Rusia perpetró en
pablogradt sigue dejando heridos en
Ucrania la cifra de víctimas ascendió a
más de una treintena mientras que
decenas de casas se incendiaron por
causa de los misiles el gobierno
ucraniano detalló que 15 de 18 cohetes
rusos fueron derribados y que los únicos
daños fueron en la localidad ubicada ni
propetrol los residentes relataron la
escena que debieron padecer en mitad de
la noche
una vez que escuché las primeras
explosiones le grité a mi esposa vamos a
vestirnos rápidamente y a salir Esto es
lo que me puse recién habíamos llegado
al corredor cuando escuché otra
explosión
fui arrojado por habla de la explosión
las ventanas se volaron es bueno que no
estuviéramos afuera porque no sé qué nos
pasaría
corrimos al pasillo nos acostamos en el
suelo y luego la ola de explosión torció
la puerta Si nos hubiéramos quedado
cinco segundos más nos habríamos quedado
atrapados aquí luego hubo una sola de
explosiones no sé qué pasó con la puerta
pero era difícil entrar en la habitación
no dormimos por la noche ni por la
mañana Mi hijo va a necesitar ayuda
psicológica es horrible
en Rusia un tren de carga que
transportaba derivados de petróleo
descarriló en la región de brians una
zona fronteriza con Ucrania la causa fue
un artefacto explosivo no identificado
según aseguró el gobernador Alexander
Bogotá las actividades con misiles rusos
se reactivaron luego de dos meses hace
tres días otra oleada impactó un
edificio Residencial y mató a 23 civiles
en tanto se aguarda por la inminente
contraofensiva ucraniana en la región de
Saprissa y en la ciudad de